this morning we focus on something that
no pilot ever wants to see a laser light
beaming right into the cockpit new
numbers from the faa show incidents of
people hitting aircrafts with these
blinding lights are on pace for a new
record the number of reported strikes
jumped by 41 last year prompting an faa
alert and a plea for people to stop
aiming handheld laser pointers at planes
pilots tell chris vancleave it can
literally be a matter of life and death
flying low over palmetto florida manatee
sheriff's watch one helicopter got lit
up by a blinding bright green laser
aimed at the crew from the ground
all you see is green
so it's very disorientating
deputy ben seahorn was at the controls
it's almost like a disco ball once the
the laser itself hits the cockpit it
bounces everywhere and it's very
blinding
oh there it is
right from the river laser strikes on
aircraft are soaring up 41 percent last
year to more than 9 700 that's more than
one an hour southwest 4465 use caution
just had an unauthorized laser
illumination event california texas and
florida lead the nation in incidents 47
pilots reported injuries from the
strikes last year the lasers can cause
temporary blindness and in some cases
lasting eye injuries and they often
occur just as pilots are about to land
and departure delta 1037
yeah we got a laser
that was pointed at us when we were in
the turn in seattle the fbi is now
offering a 10 000 reward after a
dramatic increase in laser incidents
pilots reported more than 100 strikes
since january 28 occurred in just three
days while airliners were taking off or
landing we absolutely have to be able to
see to land the aircraft it happened to
captain laura einsettler as she was
landing at lax i was flying as the
captain the first officer exclaimed ah
and
said laser as the entire cockpit had lit
up bright green the faa thinks part of
the reason these strikes are surging the
way they are is the laser pointers are
powerful and cheap we ordered this one
online for about 20 bucks pilots are
trained to look away from the lasers if
they see a strike coming and last year
washington state patrol pilots were
first in the nation to test new
protective glasses developed by the air
force research lab aimed at filtering
out the laser light to reduce the impact
of these strikes
while the number of incidents continues
to climb arrests are rare
but watch one was able to hone in on the
guy with the laser directing officers to
a 17 year old who is now facing felony
charges and the potential of thousands
in fines from the faa it's not worth it
you're going to have a bad day if you
get caught a warning from police that a
beam of light could have you headed to
jail in a flash
for cbs mornings i'm chris van cleave in
sarasota florida